hello
how is it going hope everybody's having
a great day
um i'm jose directionally in saint louis
and we were having such a great weather
um pretty much all we can somehow today
just started raining so they got that
going on
um for those of you who have been
watching me
for the past um i guess
few months at least since pandemic it
i wanted to share a little information
that
today my cat has been extremely loud and
he will most likely continue meowing so
i apologize in advance for that
hope you like cats meowing um there is a
stray cat
behind the window that i feed sometimes
and since it's raining the stray cat is
kind of like
taking shelter so yeah we got that going
um but yeah and for the other those of
you
who uh have been hearing me
vent on twitch about exams and
mcats and stuff i did an exam today it
was actually pretty nicely
i thought it would go way worse and
signed up for mcat
26th of march it's going to be
a very painful day the longest
exam of my life so far eight hour exam
i am not even halfway through studying
so yeah i got that going
um hope you guys are doing better i see
the chat is warming up
thank you thank you amsterdam i have
some friends in
uh netherlands i was there in 2015.
oh god i'm getting old it's already been
five years since i was there
oh god all right so um today i decided
to take a
step back and we are going to talk about
a little um
fun game that morphe played but it's not
just that morky played it
it's really fun because well
we've been looking at live to paul of
games and lots of
dynamic games so this game is a really
nice mix
of dynamic and strategic so hope you
guys will like it um
last week i kind of had to rush into
the last the parts of the game
it was not this game it was a different
game i think the game that we were
looking at was the
um chevsky bernstein i believe that was
the game that's
yeah i had to rush into last week so uh
if you did not catch it i did a more
extensive
end game for this game um pretty much
at the um
on the twitch channel on friday so feel
free to
take a look at that as well i really
wanted to get that
out there so if you watch the last
lecture and you want more explanation
on that and feel free to check that out
but
today i hope i think i've managed my
time better
um should it should go smoother and it
shouldn't be
as meowy there we go here is the cat
alright so um you all probably know that
i'm a very big fan of morphe as well
he's one of the great chess players of
all time
oh and namibia jesus that is very far
i have never been there actually
yeah yeah i wanted to travel i remember
i used to i grew up wanting to really
travel and
then yeah somehow i just didn't really
feel suitable traveling alone all right
so
uh enough about me and my hopes and
dreams
um so in this game
um for those of you who play uh f5
this this dutch would be very
interesting so there are very different
ways to play this touch
and there's a way to go about g6 there's
different ways to try and
form this like a stone wall style so it
takes
i mean it kind of depends on
you how you want to play it but most
people kind of
um tend to go for this knight f6 g6
and unfortunately i i used to play this
as well
and then the idea was that eventually i
kind of wanted to get this e5 and so
that's just
i'm just throwing some ideas out there
for you to go look up on your own
but as the cat confirms
oh my god peachy is this drake hat his
hyping came up
all right um
okay so now
i kind of wanted to ask another question
on how do you think uh where do you
think our pieces are supposed to be as
black basically
well what do you want to do with your
pieces are you going to do this g6 are
you going to get the bishop out
somewhere
are you going to just straight up play
d5 you have a lot of options
so i really do enjoy an interactive
class
so i would appreciate it thank you
frankness yeah bishop b4 yeah
yeah there this is this is theory but
for those of us who
are not uh who do not play this it would
be a good idea to just
have a feeling of where your pieces are
supposed to be
all right so bishop b4
now what else are you going to take that
or you're going to throw in some a5 or
c5 in there
if you know the theory i would uh kind
of encourage you not to
just like telemove more as kind of like
give a
explanation and encourage the players
who don't play this
to try and like guess them off that's
something i've been doing with
some of my students by the private ones
yeah well i mean technically you could
take but i don't really appreciate the
take because first of all the pawn tanks
back
and i don't really like this pin already
i feel like if this bishop was already
back in c1 and there was like an e3 pawn
on it it would feel much more
comfortable
anywho um c5 is actually a very
decent way of playing it you could
consider a5 as well but
um yeah it doesn't necessarily
feel i mean i feel like a fox so
one thing that i've learned and i
encourage you to actually do s
watch that video that i did i think that
was actually the first video i
one of the first videos i did for
santa's chess club um
it's a game that i played uh i was black
versus nimso indian
and um it was a very interesting um
strategy game and that a5 a4 and those
styles really do tend to help you
so uh it's good to consider a5 but at
the moment
you gotta do something about the center
now i'm gonna start meowing back is she
working from home am i right some people
have kids
some people have cats all right so c5
is the best way to go um is that it's
the most
logical way to go just because you got
to have something in the center
d5 and now what and
uh fragrance i i yeah i kind of agree
with you i saw that question about
bishop v7 i think bishop v7 would also
work but bishop e7 would kind of allow
your bishop is kind of misplaced on f6
and after e4 like opponents is trying to
play e5 or take on f5 or
bishop d3 you don't really have anything
in the center to
face it off so uh yeah i think this d5
is more sorry this bishop before is more
[Music]
interesting
my goodness okay so
now um what another question i wanted to
ask was
uh do you guys feel the difference
between playing d6 now or castling
because to me honestly it's kind of um i
mean
i don't feel that much difference
because if i play d6 you're still
probably going to get this bishop out
and i would still castle anyways so i
don't exactly
feel any difference and those are like
your only two
reasonable moves you could potentially
consider h6
but i wouldn't recommend that in this
position
so yeah i kind of just wanted to bring
up that point because that was a
little um the decision between d6 or
castle was a little confusing to me but
i don't really
feel that it's too different and okay
um some of our next few moves some of
our next few future moves
it's going to be uh moving this night
definitely
uh i'm not really comfortable what i
want to do with this bishop
i kind of just want to get rid of this
night maybe not
right now but that's definitely to come
um what else do i want to do i kind of
want to
kind of like poke this bishop so we have
some variety of ideas on what we want to
do about
this position um does anybody have
a favorite
oh my god that straight cat is literally
trying to just like
sew behind the window i wish i could
actually show it on camera but
yeah it's a yeah
i i don't know if you feel bad about
this poor cat or
just kind of like i mean i beat him i
get some
faster cat mom
and just banged himself against them
into jesus
all right um
i i kind of like this idea of knights
coming to c7 but
potentially trying to throw b5 yeah i do
like that because
um the one thing that i really really
really do like about black's position
is that this this palm structure kind of
gives you edge in both sides
the king side and the coin side so
depending on
how the game will unfold you can always
just throw something on f4 or e4
or like join the v5 so i do i really do
like that we have this many options as
black
um so i kind of think playing something
like
h6 might be more reasonable right now
so yeah what do you think after h6
what do you think h6 uh what it sorry
what do you think about h6 because
h4 i mean there's g5 and f4 so i
wouldn't really exactly go about that so
when you play h6 opponent is going to
definitely take on f6
shoe
you guys like it do you like uh do you
guys
like age snakes or do you think h6 is a
little premature
uh you're correct the pawn on d6 could
be a constant weakness
but at the moment opponent has no
threats on it
so i wouldn't feel threatened i would
only feel threatened if like
opponent wasn't like 95 or started like
throwing
trying to actively attack it
i i wish i could
um yeah i
yeah that's true um after coin f6
knights can go to d5 all right i need a
minute to get the kids
i mean they get the cat the cat kid i
look back in a jiffy
and he knows it all right
cat is gonna be hugged
all right this was not how i envisioned
uh my lesson to go but i brought the cat
this should be fun
i will most likely need to get up again
because he will not be sitting this is
straight
okay i do like h6 uh why is bishop is
for bad because if bishop is 4 he gets
g5
and then f4
so yeah it's not the most pleasant
idea um
theoretically white could try to do like
a long castle style
and uh it could get a little freaky
but i kind of like it peachy pishikishi
oh my god i do never want to have kids
and work from home
ah all right guys i'm sorry i gotta put
the cats in a room
this is not productive
all right he doesn't want to go he
doesn't want to stay oh my god i'm the
second me just to take care of the cat
how do people have kids on their own oh
my goodness
all right why psychology in the title
well today i'm having psychological
warfare with my cats i guess
uh a cat mate thank you uh yeah i don't
this sacrifice is not worth it for
for uh white and hopefully
my cat knows that if he meows now he
will have to
uh endure my first love i will squeeze
him
yes um again i'm sorry about the cat i
can't really help it i
he made appearances in the u.s
championship as well
he was such a good captain though he was
just napping maybe it was this was
during the day
anyway mission f6 is the best way to go
after
h6 uh twin time six the queen takes step
six
and i think now we could actually start
considering
some ideas but i'm not
i'm not exactly decisive on it i want to
see what the opponent does
i mean if you cast a little short side
okay well now i can do e4
and now i can do like a nice jump over
right here
so i think that would be pretty awesome
but if like white does a long castle
then i don't really exactly want to
start that because that f3 g4 would be
coming up
so white in the game um played a3
and
a3 well i mean we gotta take ah i mean
we could play bishop a5 but i really
don't see any bright
future for my cat
um for this bishop i don't exactly know
i mean what am i going to do with this
bishop i guess i'm theoretically we
could
make this difference
but i do think bishop takes c3 is just
the safest way
guess the cat agrees too and all right
so now
i am going to ask you to give me a plan
on where what do you want to do with
your pieces now
and while you guys do that i'm gonna go
trap the cat in the room close the door
on him leave some food for him
they'll be fine for 45 minutes right all
right
oh my god this is now this is the chest
and psychology part
oh
i go a bit
oh my god okay so
the cat is in the room that should be
fine
ugh he can be cute but he can meow that
cat
can meow alright
this is quality yes thank you fishy has
been singing for you guys
oh my this feels like a personal concert
huh
um no the cat is not hungry there's a
stray cat out there he wants to go out
and play with him
but he's not allowed to
as long as white isn't encapsulated yeah
i agree peter i think that's correct as
long as
it's not castling yeah we shouldn't
really touch the center yet
um so i saw some um ideas about just
trying to
develop pieces a5 curve
in fact the problem is that the knights
could really jump here it gives it a
clear path
so yeah thank you
yep 97 you're gonna get the queen
somewhere around here
and um then we could potentially try to
go for somewhere like that
yeah i agree that's a that's a very
great plan thank you
okay so knight d7 and castle now
um do you guys have a preference on
where to place the queen
are you worried about anything if you
play queen g5
uh see how he has not made me crazy yet
he was a very lovely cat during pretty
much all my exams and us championship
i probably just need to get rid of the
poor strikeouts but i i don't want to
not
feed him it's i've been feeding him for
months now
but yeah it's it's a little touchy
situation
i i um i was encouraging one of my
friends to adopt the cat
and she backed out so if anybody's
around said lose and wants a
cute cat not my cat straight one
feel free to come
take the cat but yeah yeah
yeah i agree um
yeah i mean the one thing that does
worry me about point g5
is just simply f4 like i see you're uh
concerned about between g6 when you play
e5 the
e4 that would be ignited for but i think
the threat of right now f4 is much more
severe than
um potentially e4 than knight f4
so coin g6 uh who's handling the chat i
mean i'm reading it i'm answering it i
think that's handling it yeah i think
that that's
i think that's a queen g6 is the safer
way to go
and it kind of the the one thing that i
wouldn't exactly love about it is that
i'm i'm not really
gonna have this f1 i really wanted to
have that f4 so fingers x should be good
enough uh in the game white simply
played b4
so um made a very interesting move
this is not the first note i thought
about so
what do you guys think
so black to what do you think we should
do with that pond
i doubt anybody would want to actually
take this pawn
uh you don't want to give your opponent
counterplay but i guess the main
question is do you want him to take it
and you take it with the knight or
what do you want do you want your knight
to be on whoa
do you want your knights to be on c5
or
hmm
you're just going to ignore the
fragrance and play e4 well
play e4 that kind of does make sense uh
but
the other people are also quite correct
b6 just kind of a
chill move and this was not the first
move i thought about i also considered
e4
the thing with e4 is knight f4 and you
can't really do this queen g5s there is
a
potentially i want to say knight e6 then
you would have to play this queen of six
and just exchange queens
so yeah
[Music]
yeah exactly exactly arthur uh e4 is a
little premature right now so it's good
to just go for b6
but e4 is a great candidate move and it
definitely does deserve a little bit of
thinking before
it's missing it for right now all right
so b4
b6 and
white played f3 so now
black to move what do you think we
should
do and this move
i did not find it the first time i saw
this game
actually i didn't really think about it
but i saw this game a few months ago i
want to say
july august
um well i don't think it's about depth
it's just kind of about understanding
you're not required to calculate that
much you're just kind of required to
make sure you're not blubbering
in one or two moves and that's kind of
just figuring out what your opponent
wants to do so you can prevent it
a6 or a5 um
so one thing to consider uh gabu
is that right now
black is kind of more concentrated on
the
center slash king side rather than
queensland so that's why we wouldn't
really want to play a6 or a5
however i do understand why you would
want them because
it's kind of like a stabilizing move if
something like b5
now like this is completely stabilized
but the perk the
the problem is taking and if you take
with the pawn
then the rook comes to b1 and then rook
is taking over here and you don't really
want to give that counter play to the
opponent
that's why i do not recommend um
something with b6 e sorry
a6 or a5 not yet
uh you like knight f6 huh
i actually have not seen uh any
uh i have not seen this move in the chat
so uh you guys got to think a little
deeper if it was something like knight
f6 i would have thought about it
if it was e4 i would have thought about
it i wouldn't have missed
a easy move like that
so i kind of need you guys to think a
little bit
like it like up the game by maybe one or
two levels just
think a little outside of the box and
not i mean
you don't really have that many options
so
if you play coin g5 there is f4
so that wouldn't really go your way
even though opponent just played f3 oh
can you change
[Music]
could be interesting but it's
unnecessary because you don't
uh cooking doesn't really go with the
plan that morphe
did over the board
so you guys do have the correct ideas
we want to do something in the king side
uh or
center and we don't really i mean knight
f6
is too easy to move to be uh kind of
like
questioned e4 f4 f4 do not play f4
queen g5 there's still a force so now
that's the problem
like here there are still the f4 ideas
even though f4 is not even the best f4
is the
one of the ideas to consider or
something like pointy a
i don't like youtube nope that's that's
not a human move i prefer
four yeah ah
thank you tyler um i would appreciate it
if you could
share why you think s5 is a good move
but even if not
i couldn't i didn't really find h5 the
first time i looked at this position in
this game
so um yeah is actually kind of
a weird-ish combination of moves
you like you play this h5 and my
understanding is that you just want to
push this pawn and my problem was okay
but then what i play
i played all the way up to h4 i'm not
trying to really play h3 so then what
but the problem the question is not then
what the question is like
does it does it bother opponent to have
my pawn on h4
if the answer is yes go for it in the
game
white just went with bishop c2 and black
simply
played bishop b7
i do not fully understand this move
i um to me i thought h4 is the way to go
or even now something like a5 like
something some something along those
lines
a5 i'm a little too scared to play
honestly i kind of feel like
h4 would be kind of more my style
and um so i started clearing that
college yeah s5 is the psychology move
thank you for pointing that out
yeah um a lot of these great chess
players
um did a lot of psychological just
thinking
or just analyzing without too much
calculation
and that's one of the things that i
learned i've been trying to apply in my
games i play
very little chess as you all are aware
or might be aware of
if you've seen any of my streams i am
not a professional chess player at the
moment
i have a i'm preparing for medical
school exam
and it is painful however i've actually
been
winning more tournaments in last like
months
than i have in like two years so
yeah i i guess it's about quality not
quantity
i guess but yeah i've been having some
good tournaments
um just over the weekend i won the
witnessed bullets best woman prize so i
mean it was
it was kind of yeah i mean john i get
that
thank you for reminding me yeah i feel
like
but i always thought that the title
doesn't matter if you don't look at
chess that often you don't actually
practice it or play it out
often then you're gonna drop but um
i guess it's it kind of depends because
if you don't calculate
that often then it's going to be uh yeah
you're gonna get worse of calculation
but your chess understanding doesn't
really go away
so as long as your chest understanding
is intact you should be in a good
style
yeah so i agree i kind of like this idea
with h4
or a5 so to me bishop v7 i was just like
huh and the problem with
then sorry not the problem the the
confusion that i had with bishop b7
was um well can whites now just try
to like push these pawns at some points
like can i just play f4
and i um i wasn't very comfortable with
this idea
of f4 i could simply play e5 and then
maybe try and like push this
idea of taking over there or something
like that
and but somehow the king side attack
does not
feel as strong anymore so
that's kind of why i was a little um on
edge about bishop b7
yeah we could just finish the
development that is true
yeah i agree this b7 doesn't make much
sense
but that's the beauty of it because um
so
i don't play poker but i i know some
little
cute phrases so this kind of feels like
not showing
your hands uh i guess in poker that like
bishop b7 you're kind of just waiting
on your opponent to see what the
opponent does
and um this is something that i do very
frequently in my games
um not necessarily with the bishop b7 so
bishop b7 feels like a waiting move
but at the same time like a slightly
developmental move so it feels like a
nice mix
so yeah um
[Music]
if that could be youtube which would be
someone could simply just be making way
for the rook
yeah that does sound pretty reasonable
to me
okay um so
v5 could be a potential idea out there
as well but i don't really see how it's
gonna work now
so in the game white simply play bishop
a4
i kind of like it but i'm still i would
still like to look at e4 and f4 deeper
before i would make this bishop a4 move
i guess bj4 is good because no more b5
so you're kind of blocking that whole
thing
[Music]
what there's no pressure oh yeah okay um
pregnancy i kind of yeah i kind of
forget that
how do you balance a loss of a tempo
with a waiting move
so tempo or momentum
is something that's very frequent and it
takes a lot of understanding
in the middle in the dynamic games
but right now this game is kind of still
on edge between dynamic and strategic
it's more strategic
than dynamic so that's something to
consider if your game is
very attacky and you have a bunch of
checks or takes
that's that's one tempo is gonna make
that whole different
um idea it's gonna make a lot of
difference
but if it's a position like this where
you can just like
just like kind of move your pieces
without much purpose but the point also
can't do much about it
yeah thank you fragrance
yeah i feel like you're my translator in
the chat as well
all right so bishop a4 uh i wanted to
ask you guys shall we move this night or
shall we protect it
that was another question that i wanted
to ask because
it's kind of important idea to figure
out if
if you're going to actually invest time
and energy in
protecting the night or if it's time to
call it a day and move the night
that's why we hate london system i mean
i get it
but this is actually mrs dutch
i'm reading the chat and i'm getting a
lot of different ideas i'm getting a lot
of knight of six i'm getting a lot of
48s
i you're a gyroscope or yourself sorry
that was actually a very great point
that you don't really see a piece that
you would like to see on d7
so you would move it that is a very
great
observation however queen f7
if you had your queen on d7 because this
position is closed
you could potentially go nuts and start
throwing these pawns
now that's a dynamic position
peter you are somewhat correct
but morphy that's the one thing that i
actually learned about morphe this year
because i almost just imagined him as a
guy who sacrificed mice or ropes or
something and still wins the game
but that is not actually accurate he
does have a lot of strategy games and
this is one of it that's kind of why i
wanted to show this game just to kind of
get the word out there that morphy
doesn't just
checkmate he also makes you suffer
well that's a bad message
[Music]
is there anything wrong with rook d8
not necessarily i mean i don't feel like
there's anything wrong with this
i mean white could try something like f4
i guess
and try to attack this let's keep i just
go e4
yeah i don't like this bishop guys this
bishop
is not my friend yeah i
i get it why you wouldn't really want
her to be on d7
you could consider knight f6 however if
you played knight to f6
um white could still play this f4 idea
and then try something with bishop c6
that's kind of the weird part honestly
because you're not really gonna take it
because then b5 and this one is always
going to be trouble for you
um however even if you don't take it you
would still have to like defend it maybe
like queen of seven and it's gonna be a
hassle
we don't really want to deal with that
um
so arthur and great wolf i
seen your ideas i i get that you guys
don't really want to give up this night
but uh it's kind of unfortunately what
the position needs you can't just
um you can't just like nah i'm gonna
do what i want to do you're gonna have
to play this queen of seven
in the game white took it which was
actually a mistake
the best move for white would be
something along the along
bishop c6 it could have been something
so white could have tried something with
like
uh bishop bishop c6 rook let's go
v8 and sometimes rook b1
ah come on bro there we go just to keep
the pressure and
in chess the concept of pressure is
actually a very very very very strong
concept there's a lot of players tend to
miss
that's why that's another reason i like
to call this channel psychology because
it gives you that perspective that's um
of the pressure and trying to balance
between your ideas
all right so in the game bishop takes d7
queen takes d7
takes c5 of course we're going to take
with the d we don't really want to have
this passpond
the game white split f4 so my question
to you
what should we do what should we do with
this tension take it
leave it defend it i guess those are my
three options
they are grateful definitely so uh while
you guys are thinking about this
position
it's telling me what you want to do as
black
to counter counter play
the move f4 i'm going to answer great
wolf
and so something like queen f7 the idea
is that your queen on g6
the the the job for your queen on g6
was kind of done like you couldn't you
your queen couldn't have really
benefited
from being on g6 that much so that's
kind of why we would bring it all the
way back and kind of prepare it
if you take this along i take with the
queen great my queen is there
my rook is open my queen is kind of like
keeping an eye between both
the queen side and the king side so i
kind of like that idea
pushed upon gets space advantage
but if you push the pawn then your
bishop is kind of dead
so i guess i mean i guess your bishop is
dead now anyways
um e4 does seem to be the best way to go
about it you do get the space
and essentially you might want to
launch some sort of attack on c4 or just
not like
move your bishop around a little i mean
so very very slim possibility
yeah um
so i i see your idea uh that you would
want to prefer to be white after e4
so how would you play this if you were
white
uh arthur believe me i get it if it was
up to me i would want to have a bishop
on e4 instead of a pawn on e4
however we kind of have to
compromise and in this position
the best way to do that is to kind of
have that
because if you take it it just takes for
the night and
now you have so many holes
if you don't take it then he's gonna
take it
and then this is gonna be a past pawn
so that's another issue so you kind of
have to play this f4
sorry this e4
oh hi i see people are joining us every
minute that is pretty awesome
yeah um
i'm reading the chat it kind of makes
sense um
white needs to step back from yeah so
my biggest worry in this position for
myself
as black is what the heck am i gonna do
with this bishop
where am i gonna put this bishop so
that's kind of like the biggest thing to
have to deal with
so we're kind of i feel like we're just
gonna wait and see what white's gonna do
because ideally we're gonna throw this
around but it would be nice if there's
like a pawn on a4
so you're just trying to gain as much as
a space as possible as
black
yeah i agree white does seem to be um
doing slightly better just because of
the knight
um alright so do you guys have a move
for me as white
i got a lot of different moves so i feel
like you guys have this cupboard i kind
of just want to
move on from this position
oh hi steve north
ah you could try something like play c2
bounce up on to a5 and
that does sound pretty reasonable but
yeah white did play this rook b1 which
is not the best move a4 is actually the
best mode that white fails to do
um after e4 i honestly am not sure how
to continue let's say if we play bishop
a6
then rope goes to b1 rook goes to b8
yeah it doesn't doesn't feel too
comfortable for black it feels like
black does not really have an attack
anymore
and it's just like holding in the queen
side all right
so what about rook b1 why do you think
rp1 is not the best movie
oh you like to play queen 85 instead of
that
i don't blame you queen i fight make
sense too
um you're still kind of limiting this
bishop
and i i'm having a little hard time
thinking
about what to do as black let me just
get the king up
i thought there's just rooty ones
yeah you're not really gonna be that
fast huh
no i guess queen a5 works too quick is
actually more annoying than a4 honestly
away
you just stop the whole thing with
bishop a6 yeah good job isaac when a4
sorry 25 is the best way to go yeah
all right great job
so um rook b1
and in the game why black simply played
the special b6
take your opportunity if your opponent
didn't play this coin a5 to allow you to
play efficient basics
higher bishop a6 um
bring the king up i mean i was trying i
was trying to
turn some g5 make it more interesting
i mean steve north if we do that if you
just play like
um try and exchange the queens i don't
really
think it's gonna have much for you at
this point
but bishop this position for black is
much more promising
i mean of course g6 does weaken the
black king
unless you have like a king on a seven
or five male
you if the queen side is completely
closed i would kind of go for g5
but yeah i wanted to play g5 unless i'm
desperate
so yeah
yeah all right so um yeah perfect queen
cannot go there anymore we're just going
to pick up the pond
this queen if i was a move that
suggested i suggested
last one instead of rook b1 but okay
bishop a6
rook c1 and here is another great move
that you guys have already suggested so
i'm just going to go ahead and make it
queen a4 yeah you're really worried
about queen at four yeah i agree
with a4 uh huh i agree cleaning four was
great you're kind of just like bringing
this
pressure and to be honest this does feel
like
one of those nimzo the ends with
the double pawns of c3 c4 so i think
that's another thing to consider like if
you want to have that or not
some people actually do enjoy playing
with those
pawn structures i do not
all right
white skin has been stuck on c3 yep
you're correct about that
so after point a4 white played knight g3
what do you think we should do
yeah unfortunately i did not block the
cat away i put him in a very comfortable
bed with food
just slightly close the door
four cats
only ideas for the g6 huh
well not necessarily you don't exactly
have to play g6
h4 could just kick the knights
and knight there's five xs5 just feels
55 ways of wrong can i just come back
and go attack that mind
yeah i think this should be enough just
that nice gonna fall guys
so nice gotta go back now how does that
make a change
kind of yeah queen a4 is a confusing
move i agree
yep knights g3 did lose the tempo
uh if you went knight to h5 after h4 you
would most likely be losing your knight
i mean you might save it but you would
give other material on the way
so after knight f1 um our
we can't really do anything else oh
thank you i was just getting into it
we can't really do anything else on the
king side and the queen side i mean the
bishop is fine
the queen is fine so all we gotta do is
bring up the rook
white played knight d2 and now this is
actually a very cool move
i i think this is one of the final moves
that i'm going to ask you because from
then
it kind of gets a little smooth so white
black to move what do you think we
should do after a knife e2 in this
position
i mean we can't really play the other
rook debate we already have one there
we could try to prepare for it but
oh it's three new i mean even if you
were to play this h3 g3
is still an existing um issue
ah bring a rook yeah i like that
so um
uh steve norton i don't think b3 but i
do agree b6 looks pretty chill
take take white and now
as black we make the decision to
exchange not only because the exchange
is
cut in he is better for us but also
because if you played in the queen
a5 now could be just like c3 and would
force you into exchanging anyways
so queen take take b5
it's very important to throw this b5
right now because you could play with a8
but then you have to deal with the a4s
so b5
[Music]
uh in the game i believe take take wasp
happened
and knight eight five
what do you guys think we should do
yeah easy peasy okay eight
um and this kind of white one might be
seven which was very weird to me but i
guess i get it because you can make the
mistake of taking here and then just
takes over
d6 blah blah blah so it's kind of makes
more sense
for black to not take it so something
like her basics
um
yeah this is not such an easy end game i
agree
could we have tried that in five person
then let's take
where
all right for ka it's 9p7
or a6 defending my pawn defending his
pawn
and now we finally do the killer move of
bringing the king right right the
classic one
king king f8 bishop d7
no more knight e6's
that's the attack rook v8
and um
yeah i see a different language going
going on in chat it's kind of
interesting that i cannot read it
yeah it doesn't feel comfortable for
white i agree with that if you could
just kind of like exchange
those strokes wise would be done
so you kind of know what the idea is you
want to exchange
with the rooks now how are you going to
do that
so like to move should we eat the pawn
on a3 or not
this is not really oh sorry i thought
you talked about the position
oh feature oh that's like a french
english
uh i mean the thing is if we were to
actually
take this bond now there is this nasty
chick
and you can't really take it because now
you can't really stop the pawn
so you have to be very very very careful
with what you're doing
so you can't really take that
so you could simply just push this pawn
and play c4
and i think c4 is the better way to go
just because um you're gonna just say no
i don't even need to eat this pawn i'm
gonna make a queen
uh in the game white plays king f2 we're
gonna push and we're finally gonna take
and now we get c2
the funny part is that we get to tr
to do this and pick that pawn up like
king d2
the three c3
maybe not pick it up but
so yeah what do you think we should do
now as whites well i mean
that's not a question what's going to
play with king c1 we gotta eat that
and i kind of thought maybe a check
would help
i guess not never mind king c1 group 66
and now this is another way to try and
test your strategies
so white
um what's this kind of trying to defend
it's really hard that black is just
trying to attack really hard
but what do you think we we should do
now is black
oh life is much worse i agree with that
no questions there
but it's kind of about how you're gonna
do this
yeah you gotta bring in the kangaroo
like that's king f6
and g5 take that bad boy
take that bad boy and now
anybody sees a clear path to victory
um the thing is i don't really know
what's
white's idea so a lot of things should
be easy to do like king g6
h5 and g4 um
or you could maybe consider something
let's say with d5 but i mean that should
also be good enough to win but it does
significantly lowers your ease on
winning this game
so i'm just liking g6
rxc5 you take it oh no no we're gonna
take it we're gonna show
our king and pawn warper
oh yeah king goes up i think g3
wherever the king goes we're gonna pick
this guy's up and we're going to make
two queens no less than two
all right so that's kind of why uh our
k6 is required
for xc3 you take over here i'll go up
there i want to go to g4
there we go there we go
and in this position i believe
black actually did something pretty cool
i thought just tape would be enough
honestly
let me take it and then just like king
f2 and i push this poem i thought that
would be enough
but it's black quite very very
interesting let's just play with your c5
and um rook c5
kind of makes sense you don't want to
lose this pond you're eating this pawn
anyways
so i guess we can let this one slide
now you pick that up and just not this
one is becoming
clean so yeah i think this was a very
very cool game
um yeah morphing this game
had like the perfect balance between
strategy dynamic
the opening understanding like the cute
little end game i think it's really had
all of those um all of those balances
and like it kind of hits all of those
areas
so i hope you guys like this yeah um
yeah let me see what's going on in the
chat white offer is a draw oh no we're
not going to accept this this is not
leech's tournament that you can offer
take backs not take backs
i do not speak french i speak farsi i
can read arabic i do not know what i'm
reading though
um i speak english and i
apparently speak cats yeah
yeah i think we are
i think we're doing great yeah do i have
a picture of the white player honestly i
actually
do not maybe i should have looked him up
i feel like i feel like i don't want to
check it out some stuff might pop up
because
i wouldn't want to have on youtube
if i just google this name i don't know
the kitty is
a little
occupied being trapped in my room
yeah well guys uh yeah this was a very
lovely evening i had a lot of fun
and it's kind of getting really cold and
centered so i really have to adjust the
temperature
yeah i have fun with daryl ah this is
actually a nice transition i showed you
some cool end games
they finished with the end game so you
can get more end-game knowledge from
daru
and hopefully you guys are not too
bothered with the cat
that's working from home so yeah have
fun
and i will see most of you guys
on friday on twitch channel so
yeah have fun with that bye